about the Matrix you know capture
capturing and the fact that he was
released on the same day that the Matrix
was released so Satan is real gin are
real the jail is real and Jin are
actively working to undermine Humanity
the Quran is very clear about that you
know there is preparation for the degel
happening and you know what the biggest
problem how would you translate The
Matrix the satanic forces I would say
the global satanic force and here's the
issue this is the problem and I'm glad
we're talking about this on the dean
show right now because
[Applause]
alone
peace be upon him this is our religion
Islam Islam this is
how much respect I have for the faith
we got a lot to talk about last time I
saw you we were in Florida yes sir
Chicago now we're in my office now in
yours yes
from shibley's
yeah how you doing how you been well a
blessed and grateful alhamdulillah it's
a beautiful month of Ramadan and just
grateful to Allah for his countless
blessings upon us
we made it here to Ramadan and there's
so much to talk about we got the Trump
situation happening we got last time we
spoke we had we were talking about
Andrew Tate yes sir and now we got to
have this emergency meeting also he's
been released not official he's released
from the jail right but he's still in
house arrest right yeah I was going to
play this video I want to play this
video and get your reaction to that
before we jump into Trump and before we
jump into some of the other things we're
going to talk about how's that sounds
great so this is a Romanian lawyer who's
talking about now bringing us up to
speed on what actually has happened is
an interesting point because you would
think that he's already spent four
months in jail and I think they can only
hold for 180 days and you would think
okay that was counted as that but as
this lawyer is going to go ahead and
reveal it's not quite the case the law
states very clearly that even though the
house arrest is a form of arrest on
itself the total number of days that
they can be kept under house arrest it's
equals 180 days and here's the thing it
does not count to the maximum number of
days that they can be kept under arrest
during the investigation phase that
being said based on the Romanian law
from this moment they can still keep
them under house arrest for the next 180
days which is crazy if you think about
it so now comes the question is this a
move made by the prosecutor in order to
keep them detained for a longer period
of time because just think about it for
a second now that's your profession for
those who haven't seen you on the show
before you're an attorney of going on
what is it about 12 years is your
attorney at 12 years you've handled many
cases even International cases right you
talked about that in the last episode
now what are your feelings on this now
again the principles of Justice uh are
something that people literally
sacrifice their blood for you know to
stand up against tyranny persecution and
Injustice and and one of the essential
principles is the presumption of
innocence and that the government the
state shall not have the power to impede
on people's Liberty absent uh the
adequate cause absent evidence and
absent due process of law and you know
it's it's really insane their their
system of law allows the government to
restrict people's freedom and liberty
without pressing charges uh almost as if
they want to capture someone and then
fully investigate their life to find a
reason to charge them and to imprison
them and that's seems to be what's
happening with the Tates not long after
Andrew Tate publicly announced his
conversion to Islam we find that he's
being
arrested without any charges now held
for months on end and now released into
house arrest what was inspiring though
was one upon seeing his release when
he's said when he was asked what are you
going to do when you're back home and he
said listen when I was in a prison cell
I was doing push-ups and reading my
Quran and when I go home I'm going to be
doing push-ups and reading my Quran I
want you to pay attention here as soon
as he gets out this is interesting you
know if you'd reach somebody's body
language what do you see him doing here
he gets out and he's looking at the
heavens and it looks like it's a dark
night so there's nothing physically to
see there you know but it's almost an
ode uh a moment of appreciation to to
kill them like we're guessing here
obviously but obviously the the one
who's up above is the creator of the
heavens and the Earth God Almighty Allah
so I would say maybe Tate's uh looking
up and say look I'm gonna keep my oath
now to you exactly
I mean you know like brother Tom Khan
who's been standing with brother Andrew
from the beginning yes and just spoke
with him after his release and just you
know talked about the positive
Transformations he saw because these
trials and tribulations can make you or
break you I mean it's very easy and we
know people who go through tribulations
and when they're going through the
tribulations they give up upon their
faith it's very easy for someone in his
situation to see say you know I just
became Muslim and now I'm in jail
where's God's help and they turn away
from the faith but that's not what a
True Believer does a True Believer when
they are facing tribulation they
recognize that as human beings our
elevation is through our tribulation
that God puts us in these situations to
purify us to refine us to elevate us to
train us to teach us to help us abandon
our attachment to this material world to
help us focus on him and re-establish
our connection with him so we actually
see it as a blessing and and that's the
difference between Believers and
hypocrites as Believers actually
recognize that the trials and
tribulations of Life are opportunities
for us to get closer to Allah because
the trials and tribulations of Life are
opportunities for us to do acts of
worship that the Angels can't do which
is to have sacrifice for Allah to have
patience for Allah to show our Pure
trust in Allah Angels can't do that
because they're not tested like we're
tested so through our trials and
tribulations we're getting closer to
Allah than even the angels and I think
it does speak volume to see how he
reacted to that because there are people
who when they face lesser tribulation
give up Hope and Faith I mean me as a
lawyer I deal with Muslims often going
through business disputes or or divorces
I was speaking with a brother and he
said listen going through my divorce I
gave up my prayer I said my brother
you're giving up your prayer as a much
greater loss than you losing your family
that's you've lost everything when you
lose it and you have to come back don't
let shaytan defeat you don't give up
into hopelessness so these tribulations
can make us or break us that shows a lot
right now what you're just saying like
he didn't give up exactly exactly and
it's easy again imagine somebody just
becoming Muslim and then seeing the full
force of a state government coming
against him and then getting into the
why why me why why I just accepted it's
not why is it so many people do that and
and they lose their faith but again
Allah promises that he will test us and
we need to take that as an example look
I don't care if you agree or disagree
with him or love him or hate him the
fact is you have to ask yourself when
you face a tribulation in your life do
you use that to draw closer to Allah or
turn away if you turn away then you
weren't worshiping Allah your worshiping
the Dunya and when you lose the Dunya
then you get fall into hopelessness but
if you're worshiping the lord of the
Dunya you know it comes and goes and you
know its whole purpose is to test us
this is the Abode of tribulation you
know I'm reminded of a beautiful saying
by
he said that when Satan saw Adam descend
from the Heavens to the Earth he
rejoiced he was happy because of his
jealousy that's what destroys people
jealousy and arrogance the satanic
qualities subhanallah how many times
Muslims fall into arrogance and jealousy
forgetting those who are the disease
diseases of the police anyway he
rejoiced but what Ibrahim says is he
didn't recognize Satan didn't know that
when the diver descends to the bottom of
the ocean only then can he get the rare
pearls that have value likewise when
Allah allowed us to descend in this
Dunya it was so we can get the pearls
that are only found in this Dunya what
are those pearls it is Faith in Allah
when we don't see him it is patience in
the face of hardship it is steadfastness
it is fasting sacrificing right going
through thirst and fatigue for the sake
of Allah it is steadfastness through
tribulation patient gratitude and
putting trust in him these are unique
acts of worship that only we can do in
this Dunya that even the angels can't do
that allow us to get closer to Allah
than even the angels so when we look at
the example of Andrew Tate somebody who
again it's very clear he used to live a
very sinful life and nobody's denying
that right and he may have said some
problematic things and some things which
may have been taken out of context but
regardless despite all of that when he
faced the tribulation as a fresh Muslim
he stuck by the book of Allah he stuck
by his gratitude Allah what excuse do we
especially those of us that have been
born Muslim have to turn away from Allah
when we Face some hardship we need to
take a lesson this is a lesson for all
Humanity because Allah showed the world
that the most popular man the most
searched Man became Muslim then was
thrown in jail and still remained
grateful to him what excuse do we have
yeah let's get into this
when I was in jail I focused on doing
push-ups and reading the Quran
now he didn't have to do that I mean
he's just now he's not totally free yet
he's free on house arrest right he's
still coming out you know he can be very
nervous and very shy about her scared
practically not to even mention the
Quran I mean I think this is Clear Proof
against anyone who may Allah
purifier Hearts want to claim that his
his connection to Islam is about any
material gained there was nothing
material to be gained by him uh
announcing his Islam and then frankly
getting attacked from many members of
the Muslim Community and then facing
jail time
um you know yet when he was released uh
even on house arrest the first words out
of his mouth push-ups in Quran which is
I think what it's all about right Allah
loves a strong believer more than the
weak believer let us be Kings in this
Dunya and the actual let us be the
strongest we can be in this life and use
our success in this life
to be successful in the next life and
that's one of the beautiful things I
actually saw when I was hanging out with
some of the brothers who know Tate or
are friends with Tate him that I was
just in Saudi Arabia we were with Mike
Tyson we were with Badoo Jack
um Devin Haney some other mashallah
incredible champions in this Dunya but
what I loved about them is you would see
that before their Victory and after
their Victory they kept praising Allah
they put Allah first I was with brother
Badu when he won he's the first person
to win championships at the three belts
that he won first person in history and
he's the oldest person to win the most
recent championship belt that he won
subhanallah and the first Muslim to win
that belt in Saudi Arabia
the first thing he did you know we went
back into the room after his
championship he bowed down
and thank Allah we were in the room
before he went out and we're making Dua
together you know then the next thing
subhanallah no partying no alcohol no
after it was the after party was us
going to the lobby where brother Napper
you can see the video of a well-known uh
Fitness expert masha'allah mashallah
very muscular strong brother sat with us
and Badoo had been giving him dawah and
he took his shahada and actually on that
trip about three or four brothers
mashallah who are excelling in the uh
physical Sports Fields mashallah ended
up embracing Islam through the efforts
of our brother Badu it was a beautiful
thing to see and then one of the
organizers of that fight you know and
again alhamdulillah it's just beautiful
to see these people don't know this
because he wasn't public about it right
after the fight donated 41 000 to build
a Quran School in Africa and to take
care of Orphan so it's a beautiful thing
to see the hair that can come out of uh
people who keep Allah first again no one
is perfect I think as a it's easy for
shaitaan to get us to focus on people's
mistakes shortcomings or things that
they're doing that are wrong and frankly
every human being does things that they
shouldn't be doing but as Believers I
think we need to focus on the positive
and amplify that and I saw that over
there and I think we need to strive to
be strong in this life and the next and
it's great to have examples of that
masha'allah it was nice seeing uh Mike
Tyson this was his like second on my
trip and within a couple months and he
was very serious about the the alma trip
very serious and you know may Allah give
us a class I know there's a difference
of opinion on it even I worry about my
intention that's why we need to do our
own personality but you know I wanted
the world to see this because I think
it's very powerful to see one of the
most famous boxers you know bowing
himself before the Lord of the heavens
and the Earth being a proud Muslim I
think there's benefit I think that you
need to see that so of course we
documented it on social media we took
videos we took pictures but I tell you
Mike was not having it I mean he was
very frustrated with that subhanallah he
went in without a phone in his hand he
wanted to worship focus on Allah the
whole time so Mike Tyson was frustrated
with oh he was definitely frustrated
with the pictures of social media we got
to say it and and actually I respect
that about him tremendously he did not
have a phone with him he didn't want
people taking photos he and he literally
said he's like look people are giving me
attention but I'm no better than anyone
else here and I think that was a
powerful reminder again may Allah
forgive us for for the extent that we
did share on social media I do think
there's a benefit in that but but I
really respect Mike's approach on it
isn't that the the beauty of Hajj now
that's the beauty of it now it doesn't
matter if you're Mike Tyson or if you're
a king or we're all wearing the same
they're all white uh White cloth sheets
we're all equal we all pray together
we're all in the same sections there's
no VIP section none of that we're all
equal uh standing before Allah it was a
beautiful experience uh I'm no person to
go ahead and uh foretell the future but
I can kind of make a prediction I'm
inshallah I'm hoping I think that and I
was talking to actually to agitate about
this before this was like I think right
before he accepted Islam we were trying
to arrange because he talked about I I
told him this I said um in our
correspondent is that since he likes
being in the most holiest place of
holiest places right uh because he liked
being in Romania because at that time he
was a Muslim and it was a Christian
Orthodox Christian place he like being
as according to his statements I said
why don't we get you over to uh to Mecca
you know we got some people trying to
set up we can set up for you to go to
Hajj he said I'll consider it you know
so obviously this is there's an open
invitation to brother Andrew I think
after he gets out let's do it I think
after he gets out I think I can predict
him going to one of the first things
he'll do Insha'Allah we would love to
see that I think be beautiful sight to
see and we would love to continue to
join him and help and help guide him on
the journey I know there's a lot of good
brothers that would love that and
inshallah we're in touch with some
people from from the various Hajj
agencies over there so we'd love to make
it happen inshallah yeah this would be
amazing to see him also when he gets
exonerated from all of this inshallah
absolutely that he can be there just
like my Tyson wasn't with you yeah he
can be there so tell me now
what lessons what other this is a lot of
lessons can be learned obviously this is
uh there's a big test going on for him
right now
you also you posted something regarding
Trump right so to wrap this up and then
jump into the next issue I think the
biggest lesson as I reflect because this
is actually the most I've reflected on
this recently
um about what Tate being arrested after
becoming Muslim and then him coming out
and talking about reading the Quran
means and I frankly think that is
sufficient of a lesson for Humanity just
to show Allah showing the world that
listen even a person who just became
Muslim and lived an openly very sinful
life
he didn't give up Hope and Faith when he
went through difficult times and neither
should you yeah that's I think the
takeaway lesson for us that we we can
take away from it just reminds me since
we we're talking about this I had a a
friend of mine this is a story that I
was part of I went to visit this was
years ago someone from jaheliyah so I
went to go ahead and give him dawah and
he was in a federal penitentiary and I
went there to see him and as I'm talking
to him I was real surprised because this
was someone who his parents were Muslim
and then he was like he he he pretty
much solidified his he went towards
atheism denying a law and I don't
believe anybody's truly atheist but now
he went away from the dean even more you
would think he would because he said I
was making Where's God why didn't he get
me out of here so he did the crime and
he was thinking like hey I'm just going
to make a prayer and these these uh
these Gates now magically are going to
just open right sure so now contrast
that with another individual who was in
jail this is another is a person a
friend of my father's from a long time
ago so someone from John halia my father
was giving him dawa and he was talking
narrating his story and I connected
these two and I want to get your
feedback on this so so you have one
scenario here this person he goes in
jail he does a crime instead of now you
know turning his life around he makes a
prayer and he's he's expecting doors
just to open this other person is in the
jail now there's another individual he's
praying to God he's talking about he's
earnestly praying next thing you know he
knows he's got to do the time but he
ends up meeting someone from Bosnia
who's working in the prison facility who
may who pretty much is from a town that
his father was from and this person they
get acquainted so he's bringing him
extra food he's helping him out so it
pretty much helped his stay there so
Allah was helping him and this means you
follow me so you got two different ways
perspectives you can look at at things
absolutely same thing with Tate now
being released during Ramadan
released in Ramadan and for those that
follow the whole Matrix thing which is
interesting yeah I was going to ask
that's good you brought that up we'll
get to that but uh go ahead well I'm
just gonna say it was interesting for
the Matrix fans because he always talks
about the Matrix which is the idea that
we're in this manufactured construct not
necessarily now what do you think before
you get into the Matrix I want to get
into that deeper but what do you think
about these scenarios now you hear this
now my prayer is not answered so there's
no this is the point I want to jump in
because I want to contrast that uh with
an example an experience that I had in
Florida right so you have this example
of somebody going through Great
Tribulation and using that to draw
closer to Allah
whereas you have many people who
unfortunately react in the opposite
direction and and I saw that in Florida
in Florida I I you know I I started
keeping in touch with one of the leaders
of the biggest anti-muslim hate groups
and he was a devout Christian and he ran
one of the most nasty anti-muslim hate
groups but subhanallah when you when
you're a person of honor and you treat
others honorably you know Allah instills
respect in people's hearts yes so
Savannah took my number he was always
respectful towards me he kept in touch
very cordial
and he invited me to visit his home
so I visited him in his house and he's
around nine years old now and I was
shocked to see 90 years old 90 years old
and this is uh one of the leading
leaders and he's now he was no longer
when I knew him he was like when I first
went he was like 80. and he was leading
one of the biggest anti-muslim hate
groups now he's leading islamopholes in
Florida or in the country in Florida in
Florida in Florida
and when I when I visited him now you
know after knowing him for about almost
10 years I wish someone might think why
are you keeping in touch with him this
islamophone because this is our job
we're you know it Allah didn't send the
messengers to Muslims he sent them to
those who disbelieved yes to those who
fought against and it is our character
through Allah's tawfiq it's actually
Allah but using good character that will
turn our worst enemies and our best
friends I mean I had that I remember
attending an anti-muslim protest against
Islamic Relief by you know Maga hat
wearers pro-trump supporters who are
protesting Islam I went out spoke to
them we became friends I got a selfie we
all to get together at the end and then
one of them actually ended up becoming
Muslim afterwards wow until Kershaw at
my office so this is our job we you know
I hate this idea we take oh it's listen
we are oppressed and we shouldn't have
to educate our oppressors like get get
out of here with that nonsense it is our
job to proudly stand for our faith and
invite all Humanity to it and and wish
goodness for them I mean these are the
creation of Allah Allah made this person
he made his soul he made his body we
don't want anyone to go through torment
we don't want anyone to be miserable in
the Hereafter we want goodness for all
Humanity that is
to all creation the prophetam wished for
guidance for his worst enemies and and
this is a miracle a prophetic miracle
that same person you remember when they
were doing the Treaty of habibia one of
the polytheists at the time was doing a
treaty against the Muslims and erased
that Muhammad is the messenger of Allah
from the treaty and he's like if you're
a messenger I want to fought you you
know you find just years later
that same person sitting under the
prophet's camel and the spit of the
prophet's cam was falling on this guy's
face because he's sitting right under
him and he's just listening with love to
the words of the prophesy the prophet
Muhammad through his character through
his Mercy turned his worst enemies into
his greatest supporters so what happens
now biggest islamophob in Florida in
Florida they're keeping in touch and
what happened well he was inviting to
his house and I said you know what this
is the story you told me yes master I
Told You So I said let me accept his
invitation let me go and I went to his
home
and he was so happy to see me and we're
talking but I was shocked at what I saw
he was no longer not only he no longer
ran the anti-muslim hate group he was no
longer Christian
unfortunately he fell into complete
atheism
and I asked him I said you know my
friend you were a Christian for 50 years
and and look you know at least still you
were a person of the book like you you
know you believed in Jesus peace be upon
him although you believe in a corrupted
version of his teachings you know the
Pagan Roman beliefs that got mixed in
but you were still a step closer to the
to the truth how did you end up just
completely denying God's existence
altogether and and he told me that his
wife of 50 years passed away after a
severe about with Alzheimer's losing her
memory losing her identity and then
passing away and he said the suffering
he saw her go through over the last year
or two of her life
pushed him into atheism and I said
subhanallah that is the definition of
koffer of disbelief of ingratitude that
instead of thanking Allah for giving you
50 healthy years with this woman you
disbelieved in him because he took her
back as is the natural rule of this life
we're only here as temporary visitors
anyway yeah so that is in gratitude
instead of thanking Allah for the 50
years you had you you rejected Allah
because he took her soul back
but here's where it got really
interesting he said you know you should
meet my son I said why I said he's all
he's Muslim now this islamists
he leaves Christianity he leaves
Christianity becomes atheist but his son
left Christianity to become Muslim wow
and Subhan the year he did that he he
did really well financially so a lot of
tests people different ways sometimes
you're doing well you become Muslim test
you like Andrew Tate and you keep your
faith in this case the brother became
Muslim Allah actually opened up more
doors of risk for him so I I spoke to
him I said can I meet your son he said
no I I said why he said you'll corrupt
him you'll make his Deen stronger so
alhamdulillah what it is when I left his
son is a lawyer I looked up his son and
I actually reached out to him and he
happened it happened to be the only day
in two years he was in town so we
actually went I turned around I was
going home to Tampa I turned around I
met him for dinner and he just said a
beautiful story he himself was a lawyer
and you know he had recently gotten
divorced and he was going through
you know some difficult times and and a
client came into his office said what
are you living for like okay you're a
wealthy successful lawyer is life just
about money alcohol girls like what are
you doing with your life come let me
show you the purpose of your life and
subhanallah so he actually listened to
him studied under him
he became Muslim his ex-wife became
Muslim and then they got remarried now
they've been happily married for 15
years
fearlessly and courageously wow I
remember you telling me you were so
excited you said the story with me I
said man this is good you brought this
up this is an amazing story it's a
beautiful story biggest islamophobia
Florida he ends up his son accepts Islam
exactly it's amazing and look when you
sit with the son I mean his son looks as
American as uh apple pie you know what
I'm saying and but he's just a beautiful
soul you sent me that picture didn't you
yes we I don't know if he wants us to
talk
you sent me the picture yeah yeah I mean
I was just so happy it was you know the
amazing it was just an amazing thing how
I ended up there how Allah connected us
and it was just a reminder you know
truth will reach every household but
it's up to us to to put our effort to be
used for that or level replace us with
others now what do you think is
Happening Here Andrew Tate gets released
and then you have people now connecting
the dates the dates are showing Matrix
is released at this date same date he's
released I mean the power are the are
the uh Powers uh to be on earth here the
ones it was quite interesting I mean
look I don't know if there's anything as
a coincidence But ultimately the real
power is Allah the real power is Allah
and Andrew Tate has been talking about
the matrix's idea of a global movement
which frankly I think is consistent with
our beliefs you know there is
preparation for the gel happening and
you know what the biggest problem how
would you translate The Matrix the
satanic forces I would say the global
satanic force and here's the issue this
is the problem and I'm glad we're
talking about this on the dean show
right now because it's something that
many Muslims myself included often
forget that there is active preparation
amongst the Jinn amongst the shayathleen
to come to misguide humanity
this is a fact and there's there's
been around from the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and there are
other forces at play that were alive at
the prophet Sam that are waiting to come
out so we cannot forget and Jin are
actively working to undermine Humanity
the Quran is very clear about this you
know
Allah speaks about the shaitaan him and
his people seeing you from errors they
don't see so Satan is real gin are real
the jail is real and they're doing their
efforts so maybe I'm not saying this is
what it is but I don't believe in
coincidence everything is fate and I
also don't believe in in ultimate power
of these forces like they have power but
it's very little you know Allah is the
most powerful Allah talks about they
plot and plan Allah so so it could be an
ode I mean maybe the brother was talking
about about the Matrix you know capture
capturing and the fact that he was
released on the same day that the Matrix
was released it's just maybe there's
truth to it and again the issue is this
it's consistent with Islamic theology
Islamic theology absolutely believes
that our forces that are working for
evil around the world the Quran talks
about that absolutely over and over you
see and they promote immorality
indecency uh secularism atheism all
forms of misguidance you know the
destruction of the family the
destruction so if you want to learn
about the so-called Matrix I mean read
the book of God Almighty Allah how can
you be protected from The Matrix get
with Islam get with Islam
that's it that's it yeah never fallen to
despair see sometimes we use the evil
forces like The Conspiracy Theory mind
as oh everything is against us and we
get into a defeatist mentality that was
how this horror I mean the sahaba
recognized there were active forces
against them whether they were spiritual
demonic voices or military forces but
they said you know what Allahu Akbar
that's what we cannot forget Allah and
the crisis of many Muslims in our time
is forgetting Allahu Akbar so when we
shave our beard when we remove our hijab
when we hide almost some identity it's
because we're thinking there's forces
greater than Allah we have to please or
that we're scared of but if we recognize
Allah is greater than all of them then
we'll hold strong to our Dean hold
strong to our Sunnah and be Fearless as
proud Muslims even myself growing up as
an American Muslim attorney do you know
how many people told me I should shave
my beard to be successful to have to
hide my identity
but rather when you hold strong to your
Dean you will face attacks trust me I
face my fear but it's only Made Me
Stronger Allah promises that that when
you're attacked
and you stay true to Allah and you don't
oppress others
Allah will make your enemies attacks a
means of your elevation this is a Sunnah
so yes there's evil forces out there and
we have to protect against and prepare
against but they got nothing on us when
Allah is with us
yes absolutely absolutely so the Matrix
that's another term now that you can as
we just broke you broke down like it can
be qualified as the satanic evil forces
that are out there plotting and planning
correct get protected with your Creator
and everything he's greater than and the
unity of the Muslim Brotherhood as long
as Muslims Stand United
they got nothing on us and the prophet
saws talk to us about this I mean he he
said your nation will not be destroyed
from outside enemies it will not be
destroyed by famine it will not be
destroyed by illness or covet or
anything like that but the downfall if
it happens will happen through internal
fighting this is uh you might as you
mentioned Brotherhood that Unity Between
Brothers uh sisters in in Islam that we
come together as a true ummah of the
family this is one thing that many
people they love they love this
discipline you just had this boxer
coming the boxing one of the big time
boxing promoters I don't know if you saw
him uh Eddie Hernan he's talking about
how he's considering he's looking he
wants to learn more about Islam do you
know this box I think I've seen it and
it's just it's happening a lot out there
because they're seeing a beautiful
brother the minute you say the many
nuclear there's only one God Muhammad is
his messenger you feel the love
you you see I mean I remember taking
shahada at the university the other day
there were lines long people hugging him
and it's a sincere beautiful love that
people are lacking nowadays reminds me
of the either
are we saying now if you you you
translate this how you see the Victory
and the help of Allah come run towards
his forgiveness Mercy I mean people are
entering Allah what's happening and the
question is are we going to be part of
it or are we going to be those that
corrupted against from it are we gonna
be those that welcome people into Islam
and and provide them beautiful examples
and support them and Elevate them and
hold strong to our faith or are we going
to be those that sell out and change our
Dean and try to compromise trying to
please others and forgetting Allahu
Akbar may Allah keep us steadfast I mean
I mean yeah so this is a very I mean
very very interesting topic with the
Matrix right uh these dates coinciding
and now but he's scared now I don't say
he's scared no no um he had he had
talked about the next what would you say
the next thing is for them to try to
take them out well there's three things
right they talked about the first thing
is them trying to cancel your destroy
your reputation yeah subhanallah I've
been there we know what that's like you
know it ain't easy but subhala when you
stay true to Allah Allah will make that
as a means of a great greatness for you
number two is imprisonment and we've
seen that happen a lot we've seen that
happen uh against leaders within the
Muslim Community throughout the US for
the last two decades so number two is
that number three is assassination uh we
ask Allah but again they can plot and
Allah says this in the Quran I mean in
Russia is the problem
when those are disbelief plot against
you to to Exile you or to imprison you
or or to kill you and they plot and
Allah plots and Allah is the best of
planners so ultimately that that is a
real threat but and every soul will
taste death but only at our appointed
time the the it's not a question of if
we will die we will all die the question
is will we die on our principles and on
our faith or will we die having sold out
there was another friend of Andrew Tates
I had him on a program interviewed him
he's looking into Islam what would you
say to him this is uh they call him
money bags okay Dylan
so uh he's he's really considering Islam
and like many people from the Christian
background now they're stuck on Jesus
what do you like to tell Christians and
now they feel they have this real deep
love of Jesus and now they're stuck in
between right he's Islam is the way to
love Jesus Islam is the way to follow
Jesus Jesus was a Muslim Muslim is one
who surrenders to God he taught Islam
Islam means peace through surrender to
God Jesus was a beautiful modest humble
man he never told the soul to worship
him he always told people to worship the
god of the heavens and the Earth that
was the path of Jesus that was the path
of Moses of Abraham Islam is the
universal monotheistic pure religion and
frankly if if Islam isn't true there is
no true religion and we know religion is
true because the Holy Quran Remains the
only book that claims to be from God
that was never changed never corrupted
doesn't have different versions every
other book we know for a fact has been
changed so is the Quran is the only
proclaiming to be from God that's never
been changed and what it what is its
message by the fruits you shall know it
right the message of the Quran is God is
one honor your creator love all of his
Messengers don't distinguish between
them love Abraham love Moses love Jesus
love Muhammad peace be upon them we
follow Muhammad he was the last one and
his message was never changed and
frankly it just re-emphasized the
message of the previous prophets but
love them all honor them all follow
Prophet Muhammad and honor the Creator
by respecting his creation by being a
source of mercy first creation it's the
pure natural Universal faith I can't
tell you how many times I speak to both
men and women and they tell me they feel
like they've been Muslim their whole
life because it's so purely natural it's
not complicated you you can almost come
to a conclusion of Islam just just
living alone on a desert island you know
that all of this the heavens and the
Earth had to have a creator doesn't make
sense that the Creator is more than one
God is one that's what Islam is simple
how do you think people should because
okay you hear Andrew Tay talking about
push-ups in Quran how should people
approach maybe someone has gotten a hold
of a crime as one of these the qurans
translated by the orientalists right how
should they approach when they come to
the Quran should it maybe read a little
bit uh before that sometimes so here's
the deal the beautiful thing about Islam
is that the Quran has been preserved
purely in Arabic and it's been preserved
with knowledge from an unbroken chain of
teachers that have studied from student
to student back to the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him so my advice to
everyone is don't try to learn Islam by
studying some someone's translation of
it because you're just studying on human
beings translation and you don't have
the whole history and the context behind
the text the best way to study from
qualified teachers uh study from great
resources there's great websites out
there I mean why islam.org is a great
resource course the dean show a brief
Illustrated guide to Islam there's a lot
that's the book that I recommend yes I
actually sent this to Andrew Tate uh to
Dylan uh this is free online you can get
it it's the brief Illustrated guide this
is the one that turned that actually did
it for me it's a very frustrated guide
because it gets into all of the signs in
the Quran the proofs and evidences very
powerful I just gifted it out to someone
and and I always keep copies with me in
the car give me a copy right there so
people can see we're talking about the
other the other book I would highly
highly recommend is a book that really
increased my faith is divine reality the
Divine Reality by himself it speaks
about the islamine by our brother Hamza
zorces it's behind it it's behind it
yeah I I would look yeah yeah I would
recommend that to everyone Muslim and
non-muslim alike so you know we can put
up a picture people can see what a brief
Illustrated uh guide to Islam looks like
uh but also get the Divine reality read
I mean this is the first command from
Allah to humanity and that's the
beautiful thing about Islam Islam is a
religion that is not afraid of of
philosophy of logic of Science of
knowledge the first command from The
Lord of the heavens and the Earth is to
read to reflect you know it's behind
it's behind the Quran through that we
can inshallah you can get the pdf online
for free you can order a copy for a
couple dollars I recommend listen
brothers sisters we got work to do I
want everybody to go ahead you know find
a credible Source order dozens of these
keep them in your car wherever you go
give a copy out let people benefit from
the knowledge and children I read this
when I first started practicing and I
went through it and I said okay uh one
coincidence maybe Prophet Muhammad he
guessed this then I went to the next one
said he was a very smart man third Ford
fit I said there's no way there's no way
that he could have came up with all of
this it's impossible yeah all right so
before we come to a uh conclusion here
we wrap things up okay so we got the uh
the Quran this was the Quran that Andrew
Tate also gifted to uh the our brother
here in humanity hopefully soon our
brother in the dean our brother money
bags Dylan so he was asking about where
should he start he posted this original
this is a good translation and this was
uh he looked at it as a sign because we
ended up getting in touch with him and
right after he ended up asking people he
posted a picture of
Andrew take give this is uh he shared
that Andrew take gave him this one he
said where should he start to read and
then he talked about when I interviewed
him how he thought that this might
possibly be a sign from Allah that now
he got invited to the dean show let's
talk about the dean what's incredible
what you're doing that do you in terms
of reaching out and dawa and educating
may Allah make this a platform uh
platform for for guidance for all human
I mean I mean I mean all right so uh
alhamdulillah it's really nice to have
you here especially on such a crazy day
when when the first arraignment of a
current or former president of the
United touch upon that yes it's it's
it's it's it's it's I mean our seen as a
political Witch Hunt you know here's my
opinion on on the whole thing and look
I'm someone who who's been very critical
of trump as Muslims we got to be fair
nonpartisan we're about justice so again
as somebody I've been critical of trump
Obama uh Bush Clinton you name him I'm I
I've probably sued them I have sued
president Trump over his reasons
I mean it was clear he said he wants a
total complete shutdown of Muslims from
entering the country and then he banned
uh a number of Muslim majority countries
from from being able to send people here
the last time we gave a shout out to
actually his boy uh tarot uh tuckerson
oh yeah yeah maybe they start having
Trump have a change now too also well
there's a lot of background to that look
I think Trump was susceptible to some
bad influences like Steve Bannon and
others that tried to hijack him for his
agenda
um and I think absent maybe things could
have gone a much better Direction but
that's neither here nor there the point
is the reason I'm mentioning this is
people know I'm certainly no Fanboy in
fact I've sued the guy but I'm I'm
deeply Disturbed what I see unfolding
the reason is this I mean ultimately I
think there's two questions that are
relevant for all of us number one is did
Trump break the law number two is is the
prosecution uh politically driven and
frankly I think the answer to both of
those is yes and and both of those is
alarming see when it comes to the first
did Trump break the law the fact is
there's over 50 000 federal laws a
Harvard study has shown that the average
American commits three felonies a felony
is a crime punishable by over a year in
jail the average American they say
commits three felonies a day wow three a
day three a day because there's over
fifty thousand and how do you're not
committing it if you don't know them and
how the heck are you gonna own 50 000
laws and that's why as a lawyer I always
say never speak to the FBI without a
lawyer I stand by it you know uh if they
ever contact you contact care uh contact
my Law Firm care will do it for free
I'll charge you but but we'll give you
good Legal Office presentation but reach
out you know and never speak to them
without a lawyer because it's easy to
get yourself in trouble you don't know
the law the point is there's over 50 000
federal laws the average American breaks
about three laws a year uh a day why did
I say this because if the full force and
power of the government wants to come
after you they can pretty much come
after anyone you know imagine if they
did what they're doing the Tates they
just lock you up until they find
something they're bound to find
something on someone even if it's
inadvertent so the point is there's too
many federal laws out there America has
some of the highest incarceration rates
in the world it's a problem and and so
yeah I think he broke the law but
frankly I think
just about all of those politicians have
broken the law but they're selectively
Prosecuting him for political reasons
and I think that's disturbing I also
think it's a reflection of the of how
both the left and the right have used
anti-muslim hate before it was the
Muslim Community getting the brunt of
this extreme prosecution extreme hate
now it's being thrown against each other
and the other thing is all right you
want to prosecute uh Trump for paying a
a hundred thousand dollars uh in hush
money payments and whatever stupid
nonsense uh all of these Hypocrites are
engaged in Washington DC what are you
going to prosecute uh other presidents
that have killed hundreds of thousands
of innocent civilians made illegal Wars
destroyed Nations so please spare me
with your your cries about Justice
um so frankly I think as an attorney the
you know again as somebody who hasn't
been a fan of trump I think yeah he's
broken the law but so is every other
American because America's uh is over
criminalizes its people
and I think that kind of prosecution
therefore is political I think there was
increased uh focus on him and I think
there was ignoring others that have done
worse things like
uh crimes against humanity war crimes
illegal Wars and uh it's disturbing to
see to to see that the people who
literally have blood on their hands get
off I mean as far as I know and correct
me if I'm wrong but I don't know if
Trump has invaded any Muslim lands or
has caused any new Wars while in office
and you know a lot of people would argue
against me because I was you know maybe
too critical of trump but that was one
thing they always had on me you know you
know they would always say well listen
at least he didn't start any new
Bloodshed against Muslim nations or or
any Nation for that matter so this is
the problem it's overly criminalized and
I think the the we're just seeing what's
been happening in the Muslim Community
for a long time and for a very long time
the Muslim Community was being
selectively prosecuted and now that
those same tactics are just being used
against each other
um but it sets quite a interesting
precedent I don't think as the president
or former president you should get a
free pass to break the law and maybe
there are other things perhaps related
to the election in Georgia perhaps
related to the riots that that maybe are
more appropriate get to pursue but the
current charges out of New York do seem
to be deeply politically driven and it's
a stretch of the law at best and it
appears to be selectively a selective
prosecution which again I think just
opens the door and just shows how in
this country they can really be there's
so many federal laws that can come
against anyone I'm a lawyer but I'm not
a big fan of our justice system I do
think our justice system is better than
most other nations that being said it's
it's uh still got a long way to go and I
think Trump
he needs Islam also amen I think uh I
don't think he's too really um involved
here I think I don't know correct me if
I'm wrong that he plays this card to go
ahead and win a certain side but uh only
Allah knows what's in his heart as far
as because he comes out he's a Christian
correct well I I definitely think Trump
is just you know catering to some bad
influences you know uh you know you see
how he gets along by the way in Saudi
Arabia and the parties they have for him
I I don't think uh you know I I think
he's equally ignorant to a lot of
different cultures and a lot of
different sensitivities it's just how he
is and he's very transparent and honest
about it uh you know but you know on the
other hand you have others on the
Democrats side
what their soul hides is worth so some
people may pretend to be our friends uh
but what is hidden within their whole uh
Hearts is a lot of animosity the Trump
you know what you're getting you know
what you're getting and I this let's
close with this sincerity I don't think
any human being who's sincere and asks
the creator of the heavens and the Earth
for guidance be it Trump being anybody
that God Almighty Allah would not guide
them so I think if someone is
intelligent as can be as any politician
Donald Trump or whatnot he's made amass
a lot of money he's one of the most
influential human beings now on the
planet he's running for president again
if he was to look and to read this book
objectively with a sincere open heart
open mind can you imagine him except in
Islam man look item nothing is difficult
for Allah and look I mean I've compared
him to kharun sometimes somebody who is
wealthy and arrogant and misguided but
the fact is no one is beyond the mercy
of Allah if they sincerely seek it so we
hope guidance for him we hope guidance
really for all Humanity go ahead no
you're going no I like what you said on
the last time we met that Allah is Mercy
is encompassing we cannot restrict it
now that's it that's it and ultimately
man that's what matters look and when
you die it doesn't matter if you're a
Democrat or Republican it doesn't matter
how much money you got in the bank
matters is do you know your lord and
that's what our purpose is to call
people to that above all else to know
who they are and they cannot know who
they are if they don't know where they
came from and they cannot know where
they came from they don't know where
they're going death is inevitable our
meeting with our Lord is inevitable let
us know and meet our know our Lord
before we meet our Lord remember death
remember all that money everything that
you're going to uh accumulate in this
life is going to stay behind well and
that's why we see many wealthy you know
whether they're athletes celebrities or
or you know uh men women who live like
party lifestyles in the U.S dream King
clubs all of that but you find them
leaving that
for Ramadan for fasting for wearing
hijab for a conservative Islamic
lifestyle because they see that
following and worshiping your desires
doesn't bring peace it brings misery but
knowing your lord is what brings peace
in this life and in the next and that's
why slam continues to be the fastest
growing religion it's to liberate
Humanity from being enslaved and that's
what modern capitalist Society sort of
does to humanity it makes you sleep to
your desire to sleep to your opinion of
others Islam liberates you that you
should only be a slave to your lord and
your lord only wants good for you
beautiful beautiful hi thank you my
brother and we'll send people here to
the website you can get a free copy of
the Quran of this Quran actually at the
deaneshow.com go ahead and visit us
there and we'll send this out to you as
a gift and if you have any other
questions you can call us at
1-800-662 Islam and we'll be there to
help you along your way answer the
questions that you might have and we'll
see you next time here on the dean show
until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum
foreign
[Music]
bless your efforts Eddie
thank you
how you doing brother
all right so as you can see we're
getting to work and we need your support
so go ahead and help us to get this
where it's top-notch inshallah